so as you guys know in comics and coffee
which is the weekly series a QA whereby
I answer your questions you guys come up
with some of the craziest and kookiest
ideas for different things that could be
done and comic books crossovers and so
on and one of you guys asked me the
question what would I do if I could
create my own dream team of Marvel
Comics vs. DC Comics but then I started
thinking and I asked myself this
question what would happen if we gave
one member of Marvel Comics a Lantern
ring and if we took each of the Lantern
rings and we gave them to one member of
the Marvel community who would those
members be and what would Marvel Comics
look like as a result and so that's what
we're going to talk about in this video
so jumping into the green lantern first
of course this Green Lantern ring
represents willpower and for this person
I chose beast and the reason why is
because a Marvel Comics beast is a
character who against all odds
constantly says that he can do better
constantly says that there has to be a
way for him to succeed and so for him
the idea of pushing forward the idea of
always striving for better gives us an
idea that if any character in Marvel
Comics were going to be given the ring
of willpower it would be beast he seems
to be the best candidate for it now
his character is actually
interchangeable with the next character
the person that I chose for the Blue
Lantern ring which is the ring of hope
is Captain America and this is really
kind of interesting here now the reason
why I say they're kind of
interchangeable is because in truth for
the Blue Lantern ring the work would to
work the way it's supposed to to work to
its full potential it has to be
relatively close or to be able to
interact with a Green Lantern ring and
so with the two of them working together
Captain America could reach greater
heights of inspiring hope in others as
well as I guess maybe getting himself
out of situations he wouldn't normally
be able to get out of we could also
complement what it is a beast represents
we could compliment beasts with the
power of willpower now the next one is
the Red Lantern ring the ring of rage
and I know a lot of you guys are just
like oh who's this one gonna be this one
is the Incredible Hulk and I think
either the Incredible Hulk or Red Hulk
really had to be chosen for this
discussion the reason being because as
we know the Red Hulk is the embodiment
of rage using embodiment of what it
means to just be angry all the time but
he does not have unlimited power like
The Incredible Hulk does the Incredible
Hulk is the only version of a Hulk that
has unlimited power than the angrier he
gets the more powerful he gets and red
rings feed off of rage the rage of other
individuals empowers those rings and so
if the Incredible Hulk who already has
the unlimited potential to get angry
could then in turn use a Red Lantern
ring to channel that rage to make
himself angry or faster and reach
greater heights of strength faster than
you normally would then he would be a
force to be reckoned with it'd be
absolutely nuts to see what it would be
like with the Incredible Hulk wielding a
a Red Lantern now the next person of
course the next I guess the next ring is
Black Lantern ring this is the ring that
represents death and this one actually
feeds off death itself and of course I
think for the most part we can all
unanimously agree that the person who
should I guess wield the Black Lantern
ring would be Thanos and the reason why
I chose Thanos is because Thanos is a
representation of death he is the
harbinger of death everything he does is
for the purpose of appeasing death and
so if he could in turn become the
embodiment or the person who would best
athlete be able to kill off as many
people as possible at any point in given
time I imagine he would jump on that and
so for me fan OHS wielding the Black
Lantern ring of death is the perfect
candidate for this position there really
isn't anyone else that I think could fit
this mold quite as well as he could now
the next ring is the orange Lantern ring
and the orange Lantern ring represents
greed and this person I chose to be
Doctor Doom now this one was a little
iffy and true that was really kind of
grasping at straws to figure out who it
was I could throw and the position of
the of the orange Lantern ring there are
a lot of people out there who are very
greedy in terms of their ambitions but
Doctor Doom really seems to fit the mold
here Doctor Doom is a character who was
constantly aspiring for more power every
single time we see any kind of a major
conflict take place Doctor Doom is
always the first one to try to find a
way to bend it in his eye gets to his
benefit to basically find a way to give
himself more power we saw with infinity
war that his goal was to basically
acquire all of the cosmic hues and
eventually the Infinity Gauntlet itself
we saw him do the same thing and the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline during
Secret Wars in 1984 by Jim shooter he
stole the power of the Beyonder this is
a constant theme of Doctor Doom he's
constantly trying to gain more power and
so for me I think that his idea of greed
his position of trying to gain more
power all the time makes him a pretty
good candidate for the for the orange
lantern position now in terms of the
yellow lantern ring or the Sinestro ring
the ring of fear this person I chose was
Cletus Kasady none other than carnage
and I think some people would say that
he might be better positioned for the
Red Lantern ring for the ring of Rage
but I think with Cletus Kasady he is a
character who is insane but more so than
that I think he would just get a thrill
off terrorizing people he would get a
thrill off feeding off the fear of other
people and this I think is very
interesting
singing here because with the idea of
carnage with the maximum carnage
storyline for example he had basically
just gone about inspiring fear and then
ultimately confronting Spider Man but
he's a character who I think best suits
the role of being someone that
represents the embodiment of fear by
using the Sinestro Corps ring now the
next person that I chose or I guess the
next ring is the indigo ring the ring of
compassion then this person I chose was
the Silver Surfer and for me this was an
easy choice the Silver Surfer was pretty
as simple in terms of who it is a should
wield this ring the Silver Surfer is a
character who always tries to find a way
to I guess to reach another race on an
emotional level to reach another group
on a more personal level because a
silver surfer is always trying to find a
way to reach back to what he was when he
was Norrin Radd before he became the
Silver Surfer and so every single time
we see his character especially in
infinity he's sticking up for those it
can't stick up for themselves but
nonetheless for me the Silver Surfer is
a perfect candidate for the for the
Indigo Rae now the next ring is the
white Lantern ring and the white Lantern
ring of course I decided to give to Jean
Grey as the Phoenix force because to me
there's not a soul in the entire Marvel
Universe that is more deserving of this
role than she is but more specifically I
chose this because when she's the
Phoenix force the Phoenix said the
Phoenix itself quite literally
represents death and rebirth and so her
ability to basically resurrect life to
bring anything that's dead back to life
is fantastic is an incredibly cool
concept but it would also do is it also
give us a chance to see what would
happen if Jean Grey fought fanners and
that would be so cool
like that would be an awesome battle now
as some of you guys may have noticed I
left out the violet ring and the reason
why I left out the violin ring is
because in truth I couldn't think of
anybody who could undertake the mantle
of starpha a star sapphire I couldn't
think of anybody who could take this
role adequately so here's what I want I
want you guys to leave comments down
below and to tell me who do you think
should be able to wield the violet ring
who should be star sapphire not only
that if you disagree with my list then
tell me yours tell me who you think
should be in each of these positions of
the emotional spectrum of the various
Lantern cores
that being said this was fun just a
quick little one-off we'll probably
never do this again
but I decided was kind of interesting to
basically look at the emotional spectrum
of Lantern cores and decide who should
get which positions with that being said
I will catch you guys on peace